Donald Trump held another rally yesterday,
this time it was in Moon Township, Pennsylvania,
which is where I guess the Pittsburgh airport
is.
Trump arriving in every state and basically
telling them all the same thing.
Now, your state had its best year ever last
year.
Then the China virus came in, as he calls
it.
But next year's going to be the best again.
It's going to be the best year ever next year.
Trump seemed sort of particularly wound up
yesterday.
Maybe he was reacting to early news that the
vaccine emergency use authorization he had
been hoping for for October is not going to
happen, as we discussed earlier in the program.
Could've been anything.
You never know.
Could have seen something on the plane on
the way in that enraged him.
Let's look at some outrageous moments.
I know that lots of these rallies start to
blend together, but we are under six weeks
from the election and people are voting now.
Early voting, absentee voting.
I don't want any of this behavior to be normalized.
So we're going to keep talking about it.
Maybe the strangest moment of the entire event
was Donald Trump lamenting that he doesn't
have any friends anymore.
Check this out.
The crowd sort of doesn't know what to make
of it.
I could go up every guy.
They call me up and they say, Sir, how are
you, sir?
Mr. President, sir.
I have friends.
I don't have too many friends because I used
to be comfortable.
You know, you have to be comfortable with
people, right?
And I have friends.
I have one friend, Richard.
I talk about them all time, but they're multiply
this times.
A hundred people.
And Richard used to call me up five, six years
ago.
Let's have dinner.
All right.
Where do you want to go?
I'll go to some crazy restaurant today.
The restaurants will close the door.
I don't want to open them.
They want to make them do badly until November.
What, though?
Worry they're opening in November for.
But it's true.
So it's Richard on the phone, Richard, my
friend, for many, many years.
And I said, Hey, Richard.
Mr. President, sir, how are you?
I said, well, he's been calling me Donnie
and Don and D.J. and all.
Richard, are you OK?
Everything good?
Yes, sir.
Mr. President, sir, you're doing a great job,
and I'd like to thank you.
Good.
Richard.
Richard, loosen up, please.
You have to call me Mr. President.
I said so.
Just call me Donald.
It's OK.
Thank you, Donald.
I really appreciate it.
And you hear the guy can't breathe.
You know, he's having a hard time.
Breathe.
He's very nervous.
And then at the end of the phone, he goes,
Mr. President, again, thank you so much for
the job you did.
Hangs up I said, how can you be friends with
you know, it just doesn't work.
It's like I've lost a lot of people this way.
There is a lot going on there psychologically.
That would be great fodder for a few years
of psychotherapy for Donald Trump.
Really a ton of it.
But as a story to tell at a rally, it is bizarre
and odd.
And then this was maybe my favorite moment
of the entire rally.
Trump did the sir routine about Melania, his
wife.
So the search routine is when Trump tells
his story of someone talking to him.
He'll he'll say.
And they came to me and they said, Sir, we
can't do it or whatever.
Right.
This time he tells a story in which Melania
refers to him as, sir, outrageously bizarre
happening.
That thing would turn around like a pretzel.
And so it does move.
But they never want to show the crowds.
They never last night.
Now, I went home and I tell you this, I go
home all the time.
First lady, how do you like the crowd, sir?
I didn't see it.
Melania said to Trump, Sir, I didn't see the
crowd.
How strange is that?
Is this confirmation that Trump's surge stories
are lies, or is this an admission from Trump
that his wife refers to him as sir?
Either way, it's not exactly stable genius.
Then Trump went back to something he's been
talking about more and more lately, which
is space exploration.
NASA, Nas, as he referred to it over the weekend.
Mars, of course, as you and I would know it.
And Trump, I guess, because he's just constantly
thinking about golf.
Talked about NASA's great fairway's rather
than runways.
Take a look.
On the moon in the United States will be the
first nation to land an astronaut on Mars.
You know, NASA was an absolute disaster.
Grass was growing through the FERRETI, the
fairways to that fairways.
That's about all they use with a failing.
And now we have something right through the
runways, totally, just utterly unintelligible.
Donald Trump, I don't know if people have
noticed this, but we saw it there.
Trump does this unintentionally hilarious
thing where most people, when they read a
speech off of a prompter, the the idea is
these are my words that I'm reading.
This is my speech.
Trump reads the prompter almost like he's
reading a news article and reacts to what's
on the prompter, like it's news.
And sometimes he actually seems sort of like
surprised by what's on the prompter.
It's bizarre.
Then Trump went into these are our friend
Aaron Par on Twitter, called it Gore porn,
Gore G.O., Ari porn about M.S. 13 using knives.
It this it just just makes almost no sense
at all.
If you don't mind, Democrats will bring them
the hell out of our country.
We'll get him out of here.
Some of them are so violent, we have to keep
them.
We don't want to house them for 50 years.
But if we let them go, they come back in as
much as we watch, you know.
Look, if they come back and we don't want
it, we don't want them.
So we keep them here.
We have no choice.
If the left gains power, they will abolish.
Republicans will always they are going to
abolish.
Republicans will always stand with these incredible
heroes of ICE and Border Patrol.
You have to see these ice people.
They go into a den of MSHA and they go Almaden
a nest.
Well, you have these guys that are vicious,
vicious gang members and they go in there.
They just start swinging.
It's the craziest thing.
They love it.
Now, who wants that job?
Do you want that job?
People look, he's a tough guy.
Said, Hey, you two tough guys, you don't want
any part of it.
They're just incredible.
And they love our country.
They love our country.
Then people say, oh, they're too rough.
It's a rough we have no idea how bad some
of these gangs are.
What they do, they use knives because it's
more painful.
They cut people up again.
The crowd is a mix of people, some who will
just clap at anything.
Trump would.
There was a particular woman behind Trump,
no matter what he said, she would start pumping
her fists and, you know, cheering anything
he said.
But then there's another half of the crowd
that has no idea what Trump is talking about.
They go almost silent during these rallies
because it's all crazy.
Trump then went into the portion of the speech
which he's been doing lately, where he glorifies
violence against journalists.
Here.
He's talking about how funny it is that a
guy who was a reporter was manhandled by law
enforcement, grabbed from a grab when they
were grabbing him left and right.
Sometimes they grab that grab one guy.
I'm a reporter.
Get out of here.
They threw him aside like he was a little
bag of popcorn.
But no, but I mean, honestly, when you watch
the crap that we've all had to take so long,
when you see that it's actually you don't
want to do that.
But when you see it, it's actually a beautiful
site.
It's a beautiful site.
Trump says reporters tossed around by law
enforcement.
You love to see it, says Trump.
And again, the crowd.
Some are cheering mindlessly, but others are
sort of wondering, like, wait a second.
We we toss around reporters now that should
I really be cheering for this?
Like, there actually are some people in the
crowd who you can see are a little tentative
about what Trump is talking about and then
continuing with the glorification of violence
against reporters.
Trump keeps mocking MSNBC reporter Ali Velshi
for getting hit with a rubber bullet or tear
gas in Minneapolis.
He refers to him as the CNN guy.
He's not a CNN guy.
He's MSNBC.
Take a listen.
Go in.
We have the National Guard and remember that
beautiful site.
The street was a mess.
That idiot reporter from CNN got hit on the
knee with a canister of tear gas.
Right.
And he went down.
I've been hit.
He's been hit.
The one with the shaved head, shaved ice.
Maybe I'll do that one day.
I'll give it up.
So, again, he keeps telling the same story.
The CNN guy, the bald CNN guy he's talking
about MSNBC is Ali Velshi.
But we're laughing at media getting hit.
That that does not seem American to me.
It seems like the exact opposite of everything.
I thought this country was supposed to stand
for.
And then Trump plays up the Joe Biden dimentia
stuff and the Joe Biden is on drug stuff,
the gloves off.
This guy doesn't have a clue.
He doesn't know where the hell he is.
And they'll give him a shot at something.
I don't know.
He's going to get something.
He'll be, you know, because I watched him
so badly.
He performed so badly in the debates.
And then with Bernie, he was average, not
great.
But he got through and I said, what the hell
is he taking?
And we'd like to ask him.
And I said that we want to drug test.
We want to joke the bouquet.
They're both.
Yet Trump just continues to act like, you
know, Biden before the Berney debate was like
Sammy Sosa juicing to get more home runs or
something like that.
Very, very strange and of course, not totally
unreasonable to see this as projection.
Maybe it's Trump who's using uppers to increase
his performance and then the last one.
That's just hilarious.
Trump asks the crowd what gas costs these
days.
And someone yells out that it costs fifteen
dollars.
And Trump seems to believe it.
Energy, almost seven thousand dollars.
But we have to include energy.
I mean, how much are you paying for your gasoline?
You never saw a two dollar gasoline.
Less so less.
They go up.
It's less.
Now it's a big difference.
What is it now does.
Come on, tell me.
I haven't got any gas.
I haven't stopped recently at a gas station.
Fifteen.
OK.
Just for a while it was way under two.
Imagine being so out of touch that you think
gas might costs 15 dollars per gallon like
that would be weird for the average American.
Maybe if you live in a city, you don't drive.
You don't even go by a gas station.
Or when you do, you don't look like.
Maybe somebody might not know is where exactly
as gas.
Trump is the president and he's talking about
gas prices and someone yells out 15.
And Trump thinks gas might be fifteen dollars
a gallon.
I've had an electric car for a while.
I've not been to gas stations for a while.
But I can be reasonably certain that gas is
like between a dollar 80 and 370 a gallon.
Right.
If somebody says gas is fifteen dollars a
gallon, it doesn't pass the sniff test.
Trump is the president.
And he says, oh, it's at 15, a no rally on
today's schedule for Donald Trump.
As of right now, he is scheduled to do a press
conference.
Reminder, September.
Twenty ninth.
Just six days away, the first debate between
Joe Biden and Donald Trump.
I will be streaming it live starting at eight
thirty p.m. in the East, five thirty p.m.
in the West.
On YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And I do hope that you will join me.